Au printemps 1940, la Grande-Bretagne
est proche de la catastrophe militaire.
Piégés sur les plages de Dunkerque,
le corps expéditionnaire britannique,
affronte une situation impossible,
avec l'arrivée massive des
forces d'attaque hitlérienne.
- On a vécu l'enfer, les tripes, le sang,
les corps déchiquetés par les bombes,
et les m**** qui abattaient
des centaines d'hommes.
C'était absolument épouvantable.
Les Stukas étaient équipés de sirènes,
qui hurlaient pendant leur descente,
dans le but de nous effrayer.
Et ça marchait.
- On se faisait bombarder à longueur
de journée. Tous ces cadavres.
On priait pour être dans la bonne file.
- Un de mes amis a été
touché par des éclats d'obus,
qui lui ont arraché les yeux de la tête.
Il est mort presque instantanément,
ce qui était une bonne chose.
- Les avions piquaient sur nous.
Les soldats m'ont crié :
"Que faites-vous ici mademoiselle ?"
Ils m'ont porté sur leur
dos, le long de la plage.
- Pour la Grande-Bretagne, la guerre semblait
être finie avant même d'avoir commencé.
Le noyau de l'armée britannique est
sur le point de se faire éliminer,
sans aucune possibilité de s'échapper.
- On est resté sur la plage pendant
48 h, sans nourriture, sans eau.
Il n'y avait nulle part
où aller ni se cacher.
- Les avions de la Luftwaffe nous
survolaient, on était des cibles faciles.
- On espérait juste qu'il nous rate.
- Un navire hôpital a explosé.
Une bombe est tombée dans la cheminée
et a fait éclater le bâtiment en morceaux.
L'eau était pleine de jeunes
en train de mourir ou déjà morts.
Mais le capitaine a dit :
"On ne peut pas arrêter, messieurs."
Finalement, on a atteint la Manche,
et on s'est tous sentis extrêmement soulagés.
Une fois à Douvres, on a embrassé le sol et,
on a pleuré toutes les larmes de notre corps.
En hommage au courage de ces soldats
britanniques et de ceux qui les ont secourus,
les grands reportages vous présentent
ce soir, l'histoire d'un sauvetage épique,
que nous ne devons jamais oublier,
raconté par ceux qui l'ont vécu.
L'opération Dynamo est le moment culminant,
d'un des plus grands sauvetages
de tous les temps.
Des centaines de navires britanniques,
dont beaucoup de bateaux privés,
traversent la Manche pour secourir
les militaires en détresse,
plongeant courageusement,
dans le feu de l'action.
- J'ai connu l'enfer.
Je pense encore chaque jour et
je rêve chaque nuit à ces jours-là
où j'ai traversé tant
d'épreuves afin de pouvoir vivre.
J'ai 99 ans et 4 mois maintenant
et je suis toujours là.
- Chaque matin en me réveillant, j'y pense,
ça m'étonne d'être encore vivant.
- J'en rêve encore toutes les nuits.
- Je suis le seul survivant connu de
mon bataillon qui soit encore en vie.
Un parmi des millions.
- Plus personne ne souvient de ça.
Je parle à des gens qui me disent:
"C'était pendant quelle guerre ?"
C'est l'attitude du monde d'aujourd'hui.
- Les écoliers d'aujourd'hui n'ont
jamais entendu parler de Dunkerque.
Leurs enseignants non plus.
- Les événements de Dunkerque
sont tellement importants
du point de vue politique
et militaire mondiale,
ça m'étonne que les gens
ne s'en souviennent pas.
Jusqu'à la sortie du film, le grand public
n'avait généralement aucune idée
de ce que représentait Dunkerque.
Ceux qui savaient ce qui s'y est passé
voyaient ça comme une anecdote
de l'histoire britannique,
qui s'est produite avant que les États-Unis
entrent en guerre pour nous sauver.
C'est une histoire universelle de survie.
Ça a été un miracle en ce sens qu'autant
de soldats en sont revenus vivants,
alors qu'à première vue,
ça semblait peu probable.
Le fait que ces militaires
britanniques soient rentrés chez eux,
signifiait que la Grande-Bretagne n'avait
pas signé un traité de paix avec Hitler,
qu'elle n'avait pas à se rendre.
Si les troupes avaient été anéanties,
la guerre aurait été finie et on en
subirait encore les conséquences aujourd'hui.
- Il n'y a pas de gloire dans la guerre.
Ce n'est qu'une question de survie.
- Je suis née en 1918 dans
une famille assez pauvre.
- Ma mère n'était pas une femme
agréable et j'étais incontrôlable.
Ils m'ont donc dit que j'irais
à l'asile du Dr Barnardo.
J'y suis restée de l'âge
de 5 ans, jusqu'à 8 ans.
Puis je suis allée au foyer pour
enfants de Norwood pendant 2 ans,
et à celui de Sidcup ensuite.
Ça a été ça, mon enfance.
Croyez-moi, vous ne pouvez pas
comprendre la vie À cette époque,
c'était dur, très dur.
- Je me suis enrôlé dans l'armée
territoriale à l'âge de 18 ans.
Je l'ai fait parce que la bière
ne coûtait pas cher à la cantine,
et parce que les filles
aimaient les hommes en uniforme.
Je ne me suis pas vraiment
enrôlé pour devenir soldat.
Je suis entré dans l'armée territoriale,
en tant que canonnier antichar,
Je m'installais devant l'infanterie et ma
tâche était de tirer sur les chars d'assaut.
- Je faisais du vélo avec un ami
sur le terrain communal de Wimbledon.
Un sergent recruteur nous a demandé :
"Voulez-vous vous engager dans l'armée ?"
On a dit oui.
"Quel âge as-tu ?"
J'ai répondu 16 ans.
Il a refusé parce que j'étais trop jeune.
Attendez, je lui ai dit :
"Ce n'est pas vrai, j'ai 17 ans."
Et il m'a enrôlé.
- Ma vie n'était rien, c'est pour ça
que je me suis engagé dans la marine.
Je n'avais pas tout à fait 17 ans.
- Un jeune de cet âge trouve ça
merveilleux porter un uniforme.
- Je suis née en Belgique, à Anvers.
Quand la guerre a éclaté,
il a fallu que l'on parte.
Les Allemands ont réduit
notre maison en miettes.
On a dû tout laisser derrière nous.
Je n'avais que neuf ans.
- La guerre a été déclarée
le 3 septembre 1939.
J'ai été mobilisé à la fin du mois de
septembre, donc pas mal dès le début.
J'étais un conscrit.
J'ai bien vu la guerre venir.
Mon père m'a conseillé de quitter
l'armée et de m'engager dans l'aviation.
Il fallait se soumettre à un examen
médical pour l'armée de l'air.
Comme je portais des lunettes,
j'ai échoué à l'examen.
Ça m'a sauvé la vie, parce que la majorité de
mes camarades n'ont pas survécu à la guerre.
Mes lunettes m'ont sauvé la vie.
- Au début, on voyait ça comme une aventure.
On ne s'imaginait pas comment ça serait.
- Personne n'aurait pu deviner
ce qui allait se passer.
La Seconde Guerre mondiale deviendra
le conflit international le plus brutal,
et le plus destructeur de l'histoire.
À la suite de l'invasion allemande
de la Pologne en septembre 1939,
le corps expéditionnaire
britannique est envoyé en Europe.
- Au début de la guerre, en 1939,
le corps expéditionnaire britannique,
s'est rendu en France.
Il était composé de jeunes hommes,
qui n'avaient jamais été
à l'étranger de leur vie.
C'était une expérience incroyable pour eux.
Monter à bord de bateaux et
de trains, traverser la France,
se ruer aux fenêtres pour voir de
quoi avait l'air un pays étranger.
Comme il ne se passait
pas encore grand-chose,
ils en ont profité pour connaître
les Français, découvrir la cuisine française,
et faire des choses qu'ils
n'avaient jamais fait avant,
car ils étaient loin de chez eux. C'était
une sorte d'aventure pour ces jeunes-là.
"La Grande-Bretagne ne
se fâche pas facilement,
et n'a jamais voulu de cette guerre.
Maintenant qu'il nous a été imposé,
nous sommes déterminés à la mener jusqu'au
bout, peu importe les sacrifices requis.
Ce sont ceux qui font les plus
grands sacrifices, les combattants,
qui sont les plus enthousiastes.
- On a visité le château
de Brias, un grand château.
C'était très beau.
- On a effectué la traversée le jour de Noël
pour accoster à Cherbourg, en France,
le lendemain. C'est comme
ça qu'on a passé Noël.
- On est arrivé dans un village appelé
Gondecourt, près de la frontière belge.
Je faisais partie d'un bataillon de m****.
C'était très différent de
la vie à la maison avec maman.
Les soldats reçoivent
des rations alimentaires,
conçues pour répondre à
leurs besoins nutritionnels.
Ils nous donnaient une boîte de corned beef,
un paquet de biscuits pour chien,
et c'était tout ce qu'on avait
à manger pour la journée.
- Ces biscuits, pas
moyen de mordre dedans.
Il fallait les rompre en morceaux et
les ramollir pour arriver à les avaler.
- C'était dur.
Ils lui disaient que ces biscuits
renfermait beaucoup d'énergie.
On était bien obligé de les croire.
- Le cuisinier nous servait parfois
ce qu'il appelait du ragoût,
il valait mieux ne pas demander
ce qu'il y avait dedans.
Le corps expéditionnaire qui
débarque en Europe en 1939,
est une armée totalement mécanisée, mais
son entraînement scandaleusement inadéquat,
le rend incapable de combattre l'armée
allemande, bien mieux préparée.
- Ils manquaient d'entraînement,
ce n'était pas de vrais soldats.
- Pratiquement aucun d'entre
eux n'avait déjà combattu.
- Plusieurs de ses soldats n'avaient
littéralement jamais utilisé d'armes à feu.
- Quand on est arrivé en France,
on savait à peu près de quel côté
de la m**** la balle sortait.
On savait marcher au pas.
- Après l'instruction de base,
ils nous donnaient un f****,
on s'entraînait un peu au tir
et ils nous assigner un camion,
qui allait être le nôtre jusqu'à la fin.
- On s'efforçait d'apprendre les tâches des
uns et des autres sur les vedettes de combat.
Je pouvais tirer, démonter
une arme, la réassembler.
Je pouvais même tenir la barre
du bateau. Il fallait savoir tout faire.
En mai 1940, la situation
en Europe semble désastreuse.
L'armée de Hitler lance des attaques
dévastatrices contre la France,
la Belgique et les Pays-Bas.
- C'est en mai que les combats
ont vraiment débuté.
Les Allemands ayant gagné du terrain,
le corps expéditionnaire britannique
a avancé pour aller les affronter
à un point préétabli en Belgique.
Les Britanniques n'avaient pas reçu
l'autorisation d'entrer dans ce pays.
La Belgique devait rester neutre, et ne
s'impliquait que si elle était attaquée.
Quand les Allemands ont envahi la Belgique,
les forces britanniques et françaises,
ont quitté leurs positions en France
pour se rendre à leur rencontre.
- Le premier endroit où on
est allé, c'était Bruxelles.
La rue où on se trouvait était vide.
Elle avait été complètement évacuée.
Les civils étaient tous partis.
- On est monté dans le train
à Anvers, mais il n'avançait pas.
On est donc descendus et on a traversé
la Belgique pour aller jusqu'en France.
On a parcouru toute cette distance à pied.
Quand le Blitzkrieg a débuté le 10 mai,
c'est là qu'on a affronté les Allemands
pour la première fois.
On a suivi la rivière Dyle tout au long.
Les Allemands étaient de l'autre côté,
ils tiraient sur nos canons
et on tirait sur les leurs.
On avait un avion Lysandre dans les airs,
qui m'envoyait de l'information
que je transmettais à l'armée,
et j'ai fini par trouver la cible
et abattre leurs avions.
- Tout le monde s'attendait à ce
que chacun reste sur ses positions,
comme durant la Première Guerre mondiale.
Une guerre d'usure avec
très peu de mouvements.
Les soldats pensaient qu'ils
finiraient dans leurs tranchées
face aux Allemands dans les leurs, car ils
étaient habitués à ce genre d'affrontement.
Ce n'est pas ce qui s'est passé.
Les Allemands ont monté l'attaque
incroyablement audacieuse à travers
les Ardennes, avec leurs
chars d'assaut, les panzers,
qui transperçaient toutes les défenses.
Personne n'aurait cru qu'on pouvait
franchir une zone boisée avec des chars,
mais les Allemands y sont parvenus.
Comme ils n'avaient pratiquement
aucune force défensive derrière eux,
ils ont atteint la côte
en quelques jours à peine.
La mauvaise communication réduit
l'efficacité des différentes armées alliées.
N'étant pas soumise à l'autorité
d'un même commandement,
elles suivent uniquement
leurs propres objectifs.
- On ne savait pas ce qu'on faisait.
- À cause du manque de communication entre
les armées britanniques et françaises,
avant la bataille de Dunkerque,
aucun des 2 camps ne savait
vraiment ce que faisait l'autre.
Le sergent Grover m'a dit : "Tu te
mets à cet endroit avec ton canon.
Si des chars d'assaut arrivent avec
le canon pointé vers l'avant,
ce sont des ennemis. Si leur canon est tourné
de l'autre côté, ce sont des alliés."
Quand des chars sont arrivés,
il m'a dit : "Tire sur ces s**** !"
Mais je ne les voyais pas.
Soudainement, ce sont eux qui
ont commencé à nous tirer dessus,
et à nous mettre en pièces.
Mon canon a été frappé et j'ai perdu
connaissance pendant quelques minutes.
Quand j'ai repris connaissance,
j'ai entendu : "Monsieur,
on est vraiment désolé. On pensait
que vous étiez des Allemands."
C'était des foutus Français qu'il y avait
dans ce char d'assaut, gros comme une maison.
Ils avaient fait 17 victimes chez les nôtres.
- Ils ont appris une leçon, à l'avenir,
non seulement les Alliés devraient-ils
communiquer beaucoup mieux entre eux,
mais aussi au sein de
leurs armées respectives.
Les Alliés sont incapables
d'égaler la force et la férocité,
des attaques éclair allemandes.
Face à la puissance aérienne supérieure
de la Wehrmacht et à son commandement unifié,
les Britanniques et les Français,
ne sont tout simplement pas à la hauteur.
- L'armée allemande était mieux équipée,
mieux formée et plus expérimentée.
- Tout leur armement était
meilleur que le nôtre.
Ils avaient de meilleures m****,
de meilleurs canons anti-chars,
et de meilleurs chars d'assaut.
Ils gardaient toujours une
longueur d'avance sur nous.
Ils avaient de plus gros chars
qui pouvaient tirer plus loin.
Ils restaient hors de notre portée et
nous lançaient un obus après l'autre.
"Les défenses de Paris sont
complètement hermétiques.
Les avions ennemis rencontreront
une barrière d'acier,
qui protège le cœur palpitant de la France.
La meilleure leçon de 1914 a donné lieu à
la construction de la célèbre ligne Maginot.
Kilomètre après kilomètre, les frontières
Est et nord est de la France,
sont jalonnées de tourelles
d'acier et de béton,
reliées sous terre par de
vastes salles souterraines.
Ici, des armées entières
peuvent être cantonnées,
dans un environnement
confortable et climatisé.
On ne passe pas !
Tel est le cri de guerre
historique du soldat français.
Les tirs croisés des canons
de la ligne Maginot,
feront en sorte que la nouvelle guerre
mondiale ne se déroulera pas en France."
Les Alliés sont incapables
d'endiguer l'avancée de l'ennemi.
Dans la ville de Wormhout,
à 27 kilomètres de Dunkerque,
les troupes britanniques sont facilement
maîtrisées par les forces allemandes.
Alors que les forces de Hitler
avancent à la vitesse de l'éclair,
sur le territoire français, les alliés
semblent de plus en plus désemparés.
- Ça prenait beaucoup de courage.
Je n'y ai jamais vu de lâche.
Ce n'est que plusieurs années
après les événements de Dunkerque,
que la psychiatrie militaire,
deviendra un élément essentiel
des soins offerts aux soldats.
- Ces soldats qui sont revenus du front,
je sais exactement ce qu'ils ressentaient.
J'ai longtemps eu des flashbacks,
mais je n'ai jamais reçu de traitement,
ou quoi que ce soit d'autre du genre.
Personne n'allait en thérapie pour ça.
On apprenait à vivre avec.
- Je n'avais pas besoin de thérapie.
Je dois dire que les hommes
de cette époque-là,
étaient bien différents
de ceux d'aujourd'hui.
Ces histoires de consultations,
ce sont des c****.
D'abord, il n'y avait personne à
consulter, du moins pas officiellement.
Moins nombreux, moins
bien équipés et mal dirigés,
les alliés désespérés battent en retraite,
à l'approche de la machine de guerre nazie.
- Leur attaque éclair
avait permis aux Allemands
d'encercler l'armée britannique
dans le nord de la France.
Les chars d'assaut allemands
ayant pénétré jusqu'à la côte,
le corps expéditionnaire britannique
était effectivement encerclé,
avant même que les combats
aient vraiment débuté,
les Britanniques étaient déjà en difficulté,
et il était clair qu'ils allaient
devoir battre en retraite.
- Les Allemands nous ont encerclés.
Tout s'est passé très vite.
La seule issue possible, c'était la mer.
- À ce moment-là, Dunkerque
était le seul endroit
par où les Britanniques pouvaient s'échapper.
- Une voiture de l'état-major
allemand passait sur la route.
La patrouille a tiré sur le conducteur.
L'officier assis à l'arrière a sauté
hors de la voiture et s'est enfui.
Mais il a laissé sur le siège,
son casque, sa ceinture avec son Luger,
et une mallette,
qui a immédiatement été transportée
au quartier général de division.
Elle contenait les plans pour
le corps militaire allemand,
qui devait attaquer Dunkerque.
- Ça leur a donné 2 jours de grâce.
Ce qui a permis aux citoyens français
de quitter la ville de Dunkerque,
qui avait été lourdement bombardée,
et aux soldats français,
de la barricader pour être
en mesure de la défendre.
La situation devient rapidement désespérée.
Les chars allemands ayant atteint la Manche,
après avoir franchi la ligne
Maginot sans difficultés,
les armées françaises et
belges battent en retraite,
chacune de son côté de la frontière.
Il ne reste plus qu'une seule option
pour le corps expéditionnaire britannique,
se retirer jusqu'à Dunkerque.
Vaincus et humiliés, les Alliés
sont acculés au pied du mur.
La reddition semble inévitable.
Tout porte à croire que les Allemands
ont remporté la guerre en Europe.
- Cette débâcle incroyable, car c'est bien
ce que c'était, une écrasante défaite,
semblait sonner le glas
de l'armée britannique.
Comme elle était déjà coincée
sur plusieurs fronts,
les Allemands n'avaient plus qu'à compléter
la courbe, pour l'encercler complètement.
Dans ce cas-là, comment aurait-elle
pu faire autre chose que de se rendre ?
- Le général nous a dit que
personne ne pouvait nous aider.
Pour moi, la guerre était perdue.
- On se disait qu'il allait envahir la
Grande-Bretagne et que tout était fini.
- Je me demandais comment on aurait
pu encore gagner à ce stade-là.
On avait tout perdu, l'armée britannique
au complet et tout son équipement.
C'est dans le chaos que le corps
expéditionnaire se dirige vers Dunkerque.
- Pendant que l'armée britannique recule,
il devient clair pour Lord Gort,
le commandant en chef
du corps expéditionnaire,
que si la Grande-Bretagne
veut continuer à se battre,
elle doit organiser une évacuation.
C'est aussi évident que cette évacuation
peut uniquement se faire par Dunkerque,
car tous les autres ports sont tombés
l'un après l'autre aux mains des Allemands.
Le seul qui reste encore entre
nos mains, c'est Dunkerque.
Les soldats britanniques, eux, ignorent
encore pourquoi ils battent en retraite.
- On ne savait pas ce qui
se passait. Il faisait nuit.
On a marché, marché et
marché jusqu'à Bray-Dunes.
On a fini par décider de se rendre
jusqu'à l'endroit d'où venait cette fumée,
Dunkerque.
- On a chargé les troupes françaises de
retenir les Allemands pendant notre retraite.
On a ensuite roulé jusqu'aux
abords de La Panne.
Il était censé y avoir quelqu'un qui nous
y rejoindrait et qui nous dirait où aller.
Bien entendu, quand on est
arrivé, il n'y avait personne.
On a marché jusque dans la mer. L'eau me
montait à peu près jusqu'à la poitrine.
Les avions de la Luftwaffe volaient
au-dessus de la plage en mitraillant.
Il n'y avait pas de navire,
pas de bateau du tout,
ils nous ont fait sortir de l'eau en nous
disant que chaque équipe d'artillerie,
devait se débrouiller
pour trouver son chemin.
- On n'avait pas de nourriture,
pas d'eau non plus.
J'ai dit à mon compagnon Abby :
"Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?"
Il m'a répondu : "Harry, il y a un
vieux bœuf là, on va l'abattre."
On l'a tué d'un coup de f****,
et Abby en a coupé quelques morceaux,
en a mangé un steak épais comme ça.
- On a fini par rencontrer des
soldats, ceux du régiment du Cheshire.
Ils ont été très bons envers nous.
Ils nous ont nourris, on a mangé beaucoup
de leurs biscuits durs, des trucs horribles.
Avec l'ennemi à ses trousses,
l'armée britannique en déroute
poursuit son chemin vers la côte.
- La consigne était que si on trouvait
un entrepôt des forces armées,
on pouvait y entrer et se servir, car
les Allemands allaient tout prendre.
J'y suis donc entré et
j'ai pris des cigarettes.
Mon copilote, qui n'a jamais
conduit le camion, a pris du whisky.
C'était un écossais. Il est allé à
l'arrière du camion et il s'est saoulé.
Je ne l'ai plus revu avant
qu'on arrive à la plage.
Des milliers de civils sans défense
s'enfuient eux aussi pour échapper à la mort.
Les soldats britanniques sont témoins
d'innombrables scènes d'horreur.
- Il y avait tellement de réfugiés sur les
routes qui voulaient seulement partir de là,
ça a donc beaucoup gêné
la retraite des Britanniques,
parce qu'ils devaient partager
la voie avec ces millions de civils
qui tentaient aussi de s'échapper.
C'était le chaos sur les routes.
La situation était totalement chaotique.
Tout le monde se demandait ce qui allait
arriver, mais personne ne le savait.
- On n'avait pas le choix de continuer,
mais les Français ont beaucoup souffert.
On a vu des choses affreuses là-bas.
Les cadavres sur le côté de
la route, c'était terrible.
- Les choses horribles qu'on a pu voir,
ces centaines de personnes assassinées,
bombardées ou brûlées.
- Tous ces réfugiés avec des poussettes,
des chevaux et des charrettes.
Et la Luftwaffe qui les mitraillaient,
ça semait le chaos et bloquait les routes.
Ils bombardaient tout.
- Ils ne faisaient aucune distinction.
On a vu tant de morts sur le chemin de
cadavres pourris, de civils, de soldats,
de chevaux, de bétail, n'importe quoi.
C'était absolument épouvantable.
Malgré toutes ces horreurs, les soldats
n'ont pas le choix de poursuivre leur route.
- On voyait de pauvres jeunes
se faire mettre en pièces,
et on n'y faisait plus
attention. On passait outre.
C'était arrivé, c'est tout.
- C'était vraiment horrible de voir ces
femmes et ces enfants se faire blesser,
mais on ne pouvait pas
y faire grand-chose.
- C'est impossible de sauver qui que
ce soit quand on est en pleine mission.
On ressent du désespoir
et on fait de son mieux,
mais on sait qu'on a une tâche à accomplir.
- Il y avait ce petit garçon
qui est rentré de l'école,
et qui a vu que sa maison
venait d'être bombardée.
Sa mère et son père étaient morts.
Il demandait : "Où est ma mère ?"
Il a fini par suivre les soldats avec nous.
- Ils avançaient avec leur charrette,
leurs vélos et leurs poussettes.
Tout ce qu'on faisait, c'était
soigner les pieds des paysans.
Ils avaient les pieds meurtris et
notre médecin les leur bandait.
- Mes pieds étaient en très mauvais état.
Les soldats me portaient sur leur dos
parce que je ne pouvais plus marcher.
Je n'étais qu'une enfant.
C'était horrible, mon père a renoncé.
Il ne voulait plus, il a dit :
"Je n'irai pas plus loin,
les Boches peuvent m'avoir."
C'est dans les profonds tunnels
s'étendant sous le château de Douvres,
que les Britanniques commencent
à élaborer l'opération Dynamo.
- Le grand responsable de l'évacuation
était le vice-amiral Bertram Ramsay,
un vieil homme de confiance de la marine,
qui a été placé dans une
situation extrêmement difficile.
Il travaillait à Douvres, dans
la salle de la Dynamo du Château.
- C'est d'ici qu'est parti le message comme
quoi l'opération Dynamo allait commencer.
Ce sauvetage n'a rien d'une
opération militaire ordinaire.
Le vice-amiral Ramsay
conçoit un plan d'évacuation,
qui implique plus de 900 embarcations.
- La Luftwaffe avait presque entièrement
détruit le port de Dunkerque.
- Le port était presque inutilisable,
il ne restait donc que les plages.
- Le problème, c'est que les navires étaient
trop gros pour s'approcher des plages,
car la mer y était très peu profonde.
- C'était de vastes plages
plates jalonnées de dunes.
C'est génial pour se faire bronzer,
mais si on essaie d'amener de gros
destroyers jusqu'à la plage,
pour que des hommes qui
s'y trouvent montent à bord,
ils ont découvert que c'était impossible.
- Ce dont ils avaient besoin,
c'était de plus petits bateaux,
pour transporter les soldats
depuis les plages,
jusqu'aux grands navires militaires
et civils au large de la côte.
Le gouvernement britannique lance un appel
aux propriétaires de petites embarcations,
afin qu'ils participent à
cette mission de sauvetage,
qui deviendra la plus grande
évacuation de l'histoire militaire.
- Aux grands maux les grands remèdes.
- L'appel a été lancé à la radio,
c'est tout ce que les gens savaient.
- Ce n'est que très tard,
pendant l'évacuation,
que les journaux et la radio ont
rapporté qu'elle était en cours.
Ça avait été gardé secret.
- Tout s'est déroulé très rapidement.
Ils ont réquisitionné les navires du jour
au lendemain. C'était le chaos organisé.
- Bien des propriétaires ignoraient que
leur bateau avait été réquisitionné.
- Si le propriétaire se
trouvait aux alentours,
ils pouvaient participer au sauvetage.
Sinon, la marine prenait
quand même son bateau.
Plusieurs des soldats qui arrivent
épuisés aux abords de Dunkerque,
n'ont pas mangé depuis des jours.
- J'ai conduit pendant 48 h,
je m'endormais au volant,
et je me réveillais quand
je frappais la bordure de la route.
Finalement, je suis arrivé à la plage.
- Je suis entré dans un café et j'ai demandé
s'ils pouvaient remplir nos bouteilles d'eau,
parce qu'on n'avait rien à boire.
La dame m'a dit :"Je suis désolé,
il n'y a plus d'eau à Dunkerque.
Les Allemands ont fait
sauter le réseau d'eau."
Elle m'a quand même offert
de les remplir de vin rouge.
Alors, on a bu du vin rouge sur la plage.
Dunkerque est un véritable
désastre pour l'armée britannique,
qui y perd une grande partie
de son équipement militaire.
- À leur arrivée à Dunkerque,
les soldats ont été surpris d'apprendre
qu'ils allaient devoir faire
sauter leurs voitures, leurs chars,
tout ce qu'ils avaient
utilisé pour se rendre là.
- La grande majorité de l'équipement,
que l'armée britannique avait
emporté en France a été perdue.
Il a fallu abandonner toute l'artillerie
lourde, et presque tous les véhicules,
c'était impossible de les rapporter
de l'autre côté de la Manche.
- Ils ont reçu l'ordre de mettre
du sable dans les réservoirs à essence,
pour faire bloquer les moteurs,
parce qu'il ne fallait pas que les
Allemands puissent utiliser l'équipement.
- Une fois rendu à la plage,
le lieutenant m'a dit :
"Tu es de l'armée de l'air et ces
hommes sont tous de l'armée de terre.
S'ils t'attrapent, ils vont te tabasser, car
ils n'ont jamais vu d'avion venir les aider."
Il m'a donc conseillé d'enlever mes souliers,
et de mettre des bottes, un imperméable
et un casque en métal,
comme ça, j'étais complètement
déguisé en soldat de l'armée de terre.
Les dizaines de milliers de soldats
rassemblés sur le sable des plages
de Dunkerque, sont témoins de scènes de
destruction, qu'ils n'oublieront jamais.
- Tout était en feu sur la plage.
On se faisait attaquer par des bombardiers,
et les stukas descendaient
en piqué vers la plage.
Les gens ne s'imaginent pas ça, mais on
voyait tous nos amis se faire pulvériser,
des navires exploser en morceaux.
On entendait les canons tonner.
- On était impuissant,
sans endroit où s'abriter.
On se couchait dans le sable.
J'étais caché derrière
un grand banc de sable,
et je pouvais entendre les
balles pénétrer de l'autre côté.
- Il fallait se coucher dans le sable,
c'était assez déplaisant.
- Les chasseurs et les
bombardiers survolaient
la plage sans arrêt en mitraillant.
On n'avait aucun moyen de protection,
alors on restait assis sur le sable.
Il n'y avait nulle part où aller,
on espérait juste qu'ils nous ratent.
Là où je me trouvais sur la plage,
il n'y avait pas d'officier du tout.
Il fallait qu'on se débrouille tout seul.
- Je ne me rappelle pas avoir vu
un officier là, c'était chacun pour soi.
Le moral est au plus bas parmi
les troupes qui attendent les secours.
Sans ravitaillement et sans grand espoir.
- Environ 4 jours sans
nourriture, sans eau, sans rien.
- Il y en a, je suppose,
qui ont fini par abandonner.
Je ne saurai dire.
- Ce sentiment de désespoir
ne quittait jamais notre esprit.
On ne savait pas ce qui allait se passer.
- On était hébété, incapable de penser.
On se demandait bien
ce qui allait arriver.
Contraint d'attendre sous
une pluie de bombes,
les soldats sans défense ont l'impression
d'être abandonnés par la Royal Air Force.
- Le sentiment général parmi
les soldats sur la plage,
était que la RAF les avait abandonnés.
- La puissance de défense était insuffisante.
Où étaient les canons anti-
aériens ? Il n'y en avait pas.
Je n'ai pas vu un seul avion britannique.
- Ils n'ont pas fait grand-chose. Il faut
dire qu'on n'avait pas beaucoup d'avions.
- Les soldats et les marins critiquaient
la RAF et le commandement des chasseurs,
qui ne venaient pas les défendre à Dunkerque.
Chaque fois qu'ils levaient les yeux vers
le ciel, ils ne voyaient que des Allemands.
Des aviateurs dont l'avion avait été
abattu ou qui travaillaient au sol,
tentaient eux aussi de monter
à bord des navires pour rentrer au pays.
Ils se sont fait repousser et même
attaquer par des gens qui leur disaient :
"Vous n'avez rien fait pour nous aider."
Ils étaient détestés à ce point-là.
- Je trouvais ça un peu déplacé.
- Une fois rentrés en Angleterre, on a su que
la RAF protégeait les troupes sur la plage,
mais pas sur notre plage.
Affaiblis par les pertes subies
durant la campagne française,
la RAF n'est pas en mesure
d'arrêter l'assaut aérien allemand.
Cela dit, elle peut certes l'entraver.
- Les soldats et les marins croyaient tout
simplement que la RAF n'était pas là,
ce qui était vraiment injuste parce
qu'elle était bel et bien là.
- Ils étaient là, peut-être
pas au-dessus des plages,
mais un peu plus loin sur terre ou en mer.
Bien sûr, avec la bataille d'Angleterre,
l'attitude envers les membres de la RAF
a changé. Ils sont devenus
les héros de la nation.
Pendant que les divisions allemandes
s'entassent autour de Dunkerque,
le corps expéditionnaire britannique
est au bord de l'anéantissement.
Son sort en équilibre sur le fil du rasoir.
Le 27 mai 1940, le capitaine William
Tennant, officier supérieur de la Marine,
arrive à Dunkerque pour
coordonner l'évacuation.
- Tennant s'est rendu compte que
même si le port avait été détruit,
il y avait quand même un long
brise-lames, une digue de protection.
Elle n'avait absolument pas été conçue
pour qu'un navire s'en approche.
Elle servait seulement à empêcher le sable
d'atteindre le port et de l'envahir.
- Il a immédiatement pensé
à faire amarrer les bateaux
le long de cette digue de protection,
pour que les troupes soient
ensuite en mesure de monter à bord.
- Il a fait avancer un bateau le long
de la digue pour voir ce que ça donnerait.
Et ça a marché.
Des centaines de bateaux dont l'équipage
est composé de membres de la Royal Navy
et des volontaires civils, traversent
les eaux traîtresses de la Manche.
Plusieurs de ces marins assistent
à des scènes qui les marqueront à jamais.
- C'était horrible, je n'avais jamais
vu quelque chose comme ça avant.
Plein de gens se faisaient tuer.
- La majorité des petites embarcations
qui ont fait la traversée,
avaient été réquisitionnées et étaient
pilotées par des membres de la Royal Navy,
qui souvent n'avaient aucune idée
de la façon dont fonctionnait ces bateaux.
- Il y avait un bateau
avec 60 personnes à bord.
Quand il est arrivé,
il flottait à bonne hauteur,
mais avec la soixantaine
de passagers, il s'est enfoncé.
L'eau arrivait à environ 60
centimètres du plat-bord.
- La raison d'utiliser ces petits bateaux,
c'était d'amener les soldats des plages,
jusqu'aux plus gros navires
au large de la côte.
L'opération allait donc se
répéter maintes et maintes fois.
- J'ai commencé vers 9 h
et j'ai arrêté vers 16 h.
J'avais environ 3 voyages aller-
retour pour aller chercher du monde.
- On essayait chaque fois de monter
sur les bateaux qui arrivaient,
mais il se remplissait
avant qu'on les atteigne.
- On a attendu sur cette digue pendant une
éternité pour avoir une place dans un bateau.
On se faisait tirer dessus.
On faisait des signes de la main pour
que les bateaux s'arrêtent pour nous.
Beaucoup d'entre eux passaient tout droit.
Ma mère agitait sa chemise de nuit.
Elle n'arrêtait pas de leur faire des
signes, de crier : "Je suis britannique !"
Les marins sont la cible des attaques
sans merci de la Luftwaffe.
- Les bateaux se faisaient
détruire à droite et à gauche.
C'était comme entrer en enfer.
- Le tiers des navires qui ont participé
à l'opération ont été détruits,
ou mis hors service. C'était donc,
une entreprise extrêmement dangereuse.
- C'était infernal, horrible.
Je nageais dans l'eau en ramassant des
gars qui avaient perdu leurs jambes,
ou leurs pieds pour les mettre sur des canots
de fortune et les pousser vers les bateaux.
- Il y avait de l'essence et du sang
dans l'eau et quelque chose de vert.
Je ne sais pas ce que c'était,
mais c'était gluant et vert.
- On pouvait se faire écraser
par un bateau dont l'équipage
n'avait pas remarqué la
présence de soldats dans l'eau.
Il arrivait aussi que la mer s'enflamme.
Quand ces gros bateaux
coulent, leur moteur explose,
et le diesel se retrouve
partout à la surface.
On pouvait facilement
se faire tirer dessus.
Beaucoup de ceux qui sont
revenues morts sur les bateaux,
ont été abattus ou bombardés dans
l'eau par les avions allemands.
Beaucoup d'autres n'ont
pas survécu à la traversée.
Quand les premiers bateaux ont
commencé à rentrer en Angleterre,
ils ont soulevé la barrière,
et ont vu un bateau arriver dont
la moitié des passagers étaient morts.
- Quand on est entré dans le port de
Douvres, les gars nous ont tiré dessus.
J'ai dû leur dire d'arrêter de
tirer qu'on était des Anglais.
On n'était plus que 4 sur 12 au départ.
Alors que la bataille fait rage
sur terre, en mer et dans le ciel,
les hommes travaillent jusqu'aux
limites absolues de leur endurance.
- Personne ne se parlait.
Tout le monde essayait de quitter
Dunkerque par quelque moyen que ce soit.
Quand les petits bateaux sont arrivés,
ils ont ramassé beaucoup de gens.
"Venez les gars ! Prochain arrêt Douvres."
On était aux anges.
Après ça, on a prié pour réussir
à se rendre jusqu'à Douvres.
On a atteint la digue et on a fini par
trouver un chalutier, le Lord Grey.
Il y avait quelqu'un qui comptait,
ceux qui montaient à bord.
Je me suis couchée et
je me suis endormie aussitôt.
- Ma mère a eu la bonne idée de dire :
"On va éviter les grandes embarcations,
parce que les Allemands
les bombardent sans cesse."
On est donc monté sur ce petit
pétrolier qui s'appelait le Sutton.
Ils nous ont installé dans
la cabine du capitaine,
et nous ont dit que le bateau
pouvait être bombardé à tout moment.
C'était très dangereux de
passer à travers tous ces débris.
On a dû traverser du feu pour en sortir.
- Tout ce temps-là, les bombes tombaient
et les mitrailleuses nous tiraient dessus.
Certains bateaux ont coulé,
d'autres s'en sont tirés.
Des bombes, des bombes et encore des bombes.
Vous ne pouvez pas vous imaginer cet enfer.
Il fallait y être pour y croire.
On entend toutes sortes de balivernes, que
certains ont dit qu'ils n'avaient pas peur,
mais on ne pouvait s'empêcher d'avoir peur.
Après ça, on a prié pour
réussir à se rendre jusqu'à Douvres,
et on est effectivement rentré à Douvres.
C'était merveilleux, Absolument merveilleux.
Le Shangrila, le lever du jour,
on était abattus, complètement abattus.
Mais quelle sensation ça nous a
procuré d'être rentrés en Angleterre.
Je la ressens encore.
- C'était un miracle et on
était heureux d'être en vie.
- Ma compagnie comptait 107 membres.
Il y en a juste 31 qui sont rentrés sur 107.
Les soldats britanniques qui
ont quitté les plages de France,
au plus profond du désespoir, sont accueillis
chez eux comme des héros conquérants.
- On venait de perdre une bataille, mais le
peuple anglais nous traitait comme des héros.
- Ce dont je me souviens encore aujourd'hui,
ça a l'air de rien, mais
c'était incroyable pour nous,
quand on est arrivés, c'est qu'il y
avait des centaines de femmes sur les quais.
De toute évidence,
elles s'étaient fait dire :
"Dès que les navires entreront au port,
envoyez un soldat et occupez-vous de lui."
- Debout sur le quai se trouvaient
toutes ces charmantes dames,
et elles voulaient toutes s'emparer
des héros blessés comme moi.
Les femmes du Service volontaire
féminin m'ont causé plus de problèmes,
que n'importe quel Allemand.
Elles essayaient toutes de m'attraper.
Le médecin m'a dit : "Vous êtes encore
en vie, vous faites l'affaire."
- Une dame m'a pris par le bras
et m'a amené dans un hangar,
pour me donner du thé et des sandwichs.
Mon copilote, qui avait survécu lui aussi,
disait à tout le monde que
je lui avais sauvé la vie,
mais ce n'était pas tout à fait vrai.
J'avais conduit le camion pendant
qu'il se saoulait à l'arrière.
Je l'avais amené jusqu'à la plage,
et je l'avais fait sortir avant
qu'on abandonne le camion.
D'une certaine façon, on peut dire que
je l'avais sauvé, mais pas vraiment.
- Quand mon bataillon s'est finalement réuni,
j'ai été surpris de voir combien de
ses membres avaient réussi à revenir.
- C'est un miracle qu'on
ait réussi à sortir de là.
Les gens étaient très gentils
quand on est arrivés en Angleterre.
Ils nous ont aidés et nous
ont donné des vêtements.
On n'avait rien.
Il a fallu se déshabiller,
se laver et se faire désinfecter.
- Dunkerque, pour moi, ça a été
une épopée de bravoure absolue.
J'ai traversé l'enfer pour sortir de l'enfer.
Je suis revenu sain et sauf.
C'est comme ça que je le vois.
L'opération Dynamo est la plus grande
évacuation militaire de l'histoire.
Cette campagne permet d'éviter de justesse
la reddition de la Grande-Bretagne,
devant les forces de Hitler.
Elle marque un tournant majeur
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Mais pour les soldats qui reviennent à
Dunkerque en 1940, ça représente un échec.
- Les troupes britanniques
qui ont été évacuées,
se considéraient en quelque sorte
comme les vestiges d'une armée vaincue.
Ces soldats avaient pris part à une
terrible défaite. Ils sont rentrés honteux.
- On est monté sur un bateau et c'est tout.
- C'étaient des héros parce
qu'ils avaient survécu,
et ça signifiait que la
Grande-Bretagne avait un avenir.
- L'évacuation de Dunkerque a permis aux
Britanniques de rester dans la guerre.
Ça a été un triomphe.
Parce qu'ils ont réussi à secourir bien
plus de gens qu'il ne l'aurait cru possible.
- C'était incroyable combien
ils en ont secouru.
- Ils ne s'attendaient pas à
sauver plus de 45 000 hommes.
Au bout du compte, ils ont réussi à retrouver
et à ramener près de 340 000 soldats.
L'armée britannique avait survécu.
Une euphorie patriotique s'empare
du public britannique.
"La fumée de la bataille plane sur Dunkerque.
Ce port de l'autre côté de la Manche,
d'où rentrent des milliers d'hommes
du corps expéditionnaire britannique,
la magnifique opération d'arrière-garde menée
par les armées britanniques et françaises,
n'a d'égal que le splendide travail de
la marine pour protéger les soldats,
et les ramener chez eux, dans des navires de
guerre et des embarcations de toutes sortes.
Ils se battent sans cesse depuis 2 semaines,
le monde entier est émerveillé
par leur immense courage et
leur discipline inébranlable,
sous le brillant commandement
de leurs supérieurs.
Jamais, dans son histoire militaire,
la Grande-Bretagne n'a été aussi fière
de ses fils combattants."
La route sera encore longue
vers la victoire finale.
La Seconde Guerre mondiale se
poursuivra durant 4 autres années,
mais ce sont les événements de Dunkerque,
qui rendent possible cette
grande marche vers la paix.
- Plusieurs ont pris quelques
jours pour récupérer.
- On a tous eu droit à 3 jours.
- L'adjudant est arrivé et nous a dit :
"J'ai bien peur que le réveil soit à 6 h
ici. Vu que vous étiez à Dunkerque,
vous pouvez vous lever à 7 h et demie ou 8
h et prendre le déjeuner, mais c'est tout."
"Les hommes du corps expéditionnaire
profitent de quelques moments de répit
après leur retraite héroïque des Flandres.
Ici, dans un camp de repos,
ils se dépoussièrent, se ressaisissent
et se laissent aller à chanter un peu."
- Mon copain Ginger et moi, on est
resté ensemble pendant toute la guerre.
On a tous les 2 survécu à Dunkerque.
Au moment de monter sur un bateau,
on est allés dans des directions différentes.
J'ai supposé qu'il avait
été tué ou fait prisonnier,
et il a pensé la même chose à mon sujet.
Le lendemain matin, quand je marchais dans
la rue pour aller déjeuner, je l'ai croisé.
Il m'a vu et est venu me serrer dans ses
bras comme si on avait été des amants,
qui s'étaient perdus de vue depuis longtemps.
On croyait tous les 2 que l'autre avait péri.
On l'a échappé belle tellement de fois,
c'était absolument incroyable.
On était dans un cinéma, Ginger et moi, à
regarder un film dont j'ai oublié le titre,
quand la salle a été touchée par une bombe.
Plus de 500 personnes sont mortes,
mais on est sortis tous les 2 de là,
tout juste recouverts de poussière.
L'opération Dynamo a été portée
au grand écran à plusieurs reprises.
La sortie de Dunkerque du réalisateur
Christopher Nolan en 2017,
à une fois de plus attiré l'attention
du monde sur ces événements,
qui ont changé le cours de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
- Pour moi, c'est un des plus grands
moments de l'histoire de l'humanité.
Je suis heureux que certains
des anciens combattants,
qui ont vécu l'évacuation soient ici.
Quand on leur a projeté le film, ça a
été une des choses les plus intimidantes
que j'aie jamais vécues en tant que cinéaste,
me tenir devant ces gens
qui ont vécu cet événement,
et qui ont maintenant plus de 90 ans pour
leur montrer notre version de leur histoire.
- On a assisté à la première
de Dunkerque, à Leicester Square.
J'étais sur le tapis rouge.
Les gens venaient me faire un câlin.
- Ils étaient des centaines
derrière les barrières,
qui s'approchaient et qui applaudissaient
et qui nous saluaient. C'était ahurissant.
- C'était un bon film, mais
les seuls qui peuvent comprendre
comment on se sentait à Dunkerque,
ce sont ceux qui y étaient.
Personne d'autre ne peut
s'imaginer comment c'était.
- J'ai trouvé ça très bon.
Il y avait quelques petites erreurs
mineures que j'aurais pu lui reprocher,
mais en général, c'était assez exact.
- Le prince Harry m'a invité au palais.
Quel homme merveilleux !
Mais je n'étais que le deuxième homme
le plus âgé. Ça, c'est une honte.
- Ils nous ont traités en héros.
- Vous êtes des héros.
- On l'était...
- Vous l'étiez et vous l'êtes toujours !
J'espère que quelqu'un vous
a aidé à monter la colline.
Une dame a poussé un petit bout de temps.
Ensuite, quelqu'un est venu du palais
et m'a demandé : "Savez vous qui c'était ?"
J'ai dit : "Non".
C'était Kate.
Je ne pouvais pas le savoir,
elle était derrière moi.
- Il a vraiment été charmant le prince Harry.
Il est descendu et il nous a parlé.
- Je n'arrivais pas à mettre mes souliers
parce que j'ai les pieds qui enflent.
J'ai dû y aller en pantoufles.
J'ai dit au prince Harry :
"Excusez-moi pour mes pantoufles."
Il a répondu : "Au moins,
elles sont bleues royal."
- Le prince Harry nous a bien remerciés.
Je dirais qu'on a été de vrais héros
et j'ai remercié le Seigneur,
je le remercie encore.